- Bem-vindo de volta a "Entendendo Informação
e Computação Quântica." Meu nome é John Watrous, e sou o Diretor Técnico
de Educação Quântica da IBM.
Esta é a quinta aula da série, e é a primeira aula
da segunda unidade, que trata de Algoritmos Quânticos.
Nesta unidade, vamos investigar
as vantagens computacionais da informação quântica, ou seja, vamos dar uma
olhada no que podemos fazer
com computadores quânticos e nas vantagens que eles podem potencialmente ter
sobre os computadores clássicos.
Vamos nos concentrar no que podemos fazer com um único computador quântico, em vez de um ambiente distribuído,
por exemplo,
onde vários computadores quânticos interagem através de algum tipo de rede.
Existem, de fato, vantagens quânticas em ambientes distribuídos, onde comunicação e
criptografia entram em cena,
mas não vamos falar
sobre essas coisas nesta unidade.
Esta unidade é sobre algoritmos quânticos rodando em computadores quânticos individuais.
Vamos começar com uma pergunta natural. Que vantagens um computador quântico
poderia potencialmente oferecer?
A principal é que os computadores quânticos podem oferecer soluções mais rápidas para alguns problemas computacionais.
O tempo é precioso, e embora os computadores que
usamos no dia a dia sejam bem rápidos, eles ainda são lentos demais
para resolver certos problemas computacionais, justamente pela dificuldade computacional
inerente desses problemas.
Esse potencial de que os computadores quânticos nos permitam resolver problemas que os computadores clássicos
são lentos demais para resolver
é o que realmente impulsionou
a pesquisa em algoritmos quânticos nas últimas décadas.
Existem outros recursos computacionais
além do tempo que podem ser considerados, como a quantidade de memória do computador necessária para os cálculos,
mas os computadores quânticos não podem
oferecer muita economia em termos de memória, como se descobriu, e a memória de computadores clássicos é bem barata
especialmente em comparação com a memória quântica. Então, simplesmente não há
muito promissor aqui.
Poderíamos também pensar em outros recursos, como a quantidade de energia
necessária para a computação, mas você não precisa de muita energia
para computar classicamente, especialmente se você
estiver disposto a diminuir o ritmo.
Então, o que realmente importa é o tempo
necessário para os cálculos, esse é o nosso foco principal.
Aqui está uma visão geral da aula, que é sobre um
modelo específico de computação conhecido como modelo de consulta.
Você pode pensar neste modelo como sendo uma espécie de placa de Petri para desenvolver ideias algorítmicas, tanto quânticas quanto clássicas.
Ele não foi pensado para ser um modelo prático que descreva os tipos
de problemas computacionais que encontramos na vida real.
Vamos nos afastar do modelo de consulta em lições subsequentes desta unidade e focar em modelos motivados por noções
mais práticas de computação,
mas o modelo de consulta é um
ótimo ponto de partida.
É um modelo simples que nos permite explorar o
potencial dos computadores quânticos sem que muitos detalhes técnicos
atrapalhem,
e também nos permite isolar algumas das
ideias realmente importantes por trás da computação quântica e de como ela funciona.
A computação quântica de fato começou a se desenvolver dentro deste modelo, e as ideias desenvolvidas nele inspiraram diretamente
importantes algoritmos quânticos
como o algoritmo de Shor para fatoração.
Na primeira seção da aula, vamos ver especificamente o que é o modelo de consulta de computação,
e nas segunda, terceira
e quarta seções, vamos discutir três
algoritmos quânticos de consulta, a saber, o algoritmo de Deutsch,
o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa,
e o algoritmo de Simon, que revelam vantagens cada vez mais
impressionantes
dos computadores quânticos
sobre os clássicos dentro do modelo de consulta de computação.
Para explicar o modelo de consulta de computação, vamos começar com uma abstração
mais padrão da computação.
Aqui está uma figura que
representa uma computação em termos bem simples e básicos.
Temos uma entrada, que geralmente assume a
forma de uma string binária, embora possamos usar outros
símbolos se quisermos.
A entrada é fornecida à computação, representada por um
retângulo azul nesta figura,
e o resultado da computação é que alguma saída é produzida, e novamente, isso é mais
comumente uma string binária.
Claro, essa figura
não é nada específica sobre como a computação em si funciona.
Podemos formular diferentes
modelos computacionais específicos para isso, como máquinas de Turing
e circuit Booleano,
ou quantum circuits se estamos pensando sobre
computação quântica.
É verdade que esta figura
não representa o fato de que muitos dos
computadores que usamos no dia a dia estão continuamente recebendo
entrada e produzindo saída,
essencialmente interagindo conosco e com outros computadores através
da internet, por exemplo.
Mas não estamos tentando representar
essas interações aqui.
Isso é sobre modelar
tarefas computacionais isoladas.
Por exemplo, a entrada pode ser a
codificação binária de um número ou uma representação de uma matriz
ou uma descrição de uma molécula ou qualquer outra coisa que tenhamos em mente, e existe alguma tarefa computacional
sendo realizada somente nessa entrada.
O ponto-chave aqui é
que toda a entrada é fornecida à computação, e nada sobre a
entrada fica oculto dela.
O modelo de consulta de
computação funciona de forma diferente.
No modelo de consulta, a entrada é disponibilizada
na forma de uma função que a computação pode
acessar fazendo consultas,
ou em outras palavras, avaliando a função
em diferentes entradas.
Aqui você pode ver isso representado
na forma de uma figura.
Semelhante ao que tínhamos antes, a computação é representada
por um retângulo azul, mas em vez de receber uma entrada diretamente
na forma de uma string
de bits, por exemplo, ela acessa a entrada efetivamente fazendo perguntas
e recebendo respostas.
Às vezes usamos os
termos oracle e caixa preta para se referir ao mecanismo
que fornece a entrada.
Existe uma distinção entre
um oracle e uma caixa preta na teoria da complexidade, mas isso não será relevante para os fins desta discussão.
De qualquer forma, esses termos têm o intuito
de transmitir a ideia básica.
Na Grécia antiga, você
poderia ir a um oracle, como o Oráculo de Delfos,
e fazer uma pergunta importante,
e o oracle responderia
aquela pergunta específica, mas certamente não te contaria tudo o que sabia.
Numa linha similar, quando
pensamos em uma caixa preta, temos em mente algum
tipo de processo ou sistema
onde podemos escolher o que entra e podemos ver o que sai, mas não temos nenhum entendimento
de seu funcionamento interno.
E é esse o caso aqui. A entrada para o problema
assume a forma de uma função, e tudo o que podemos fazer é
avaliar essa função,
mas, fora isso, não temos
nenhum conhecimento ou entendimento de como ela funciona.
Ao longo da aula,
vamos reservar a letra f para a função que
representa a entrada, e vamos assumir
que ela sempre tem a
forma que você vê aqui.
Sigma denota o alfabeto binário, então f é uma função de strings
de bits para strings de bits,
e especificamente, vamos
assumir que a entrada para f é uma string de bits de comprimento n, e a saída é uma string
de bits de comprimento m,
onde n e m são inteiros positivos.
Para diferentes problemas, teremos
restrições em n e m, mas em todos os casos, a função de entrada vai
ter uma forma como essa.
Quando dizemos que uma
computação faz uma consulta, o que queremos dizer é que a
função f é avaliada uma vez,
ou seja, alguma string x de comprimento N é selecionada pela computação, e a string f de x é
então disponibilizada para ela
pelo oracle ou pela caixa preta. E finalmente, a maneira bem simples de medirmos o custo computacional
de um algoritmo de consulta é contar quantas consultas ele requer.
Então, embora seja verdade que
estamos realmente mais interessados em quanto tempo as computações levam, quando estudamos o modelo de consulta,
geralmente mantemos as coisas
simples e apenas contamos as consultas, e é isso que vamos fazer nesta aula.
Agora, vamos dar uma olhada em alguns
exemplos de problemas de consulta, ou seja, problemas computacionais no modelo de consulta,
e aqui, aliás, vou apenas descrever
os problemas em si, e por enquanto, não vou dizer nada
sobre como resolvê-los.
O primeiro problema é o problema OR.
Neste caso, a entrada é uma função
de n bits para apenas 1 bit, então m é igual a 1 para este problema,
e a saída exigida para
o problema é 1 ou 0.
Se existir alguma string de n bits x para a qual f de x é igual a 1, então a resposta correta é 1,
e caso contrário, se f de x é
sempre 0 para toda string x, então a resposta correta é 0.
Então, se pensarmos na função f como nos fornecendo acesso aleatório a dois elevado a n bits, um para cada string de n bits x,
então o que ela está pedindo
é o OR desses bits, e é por isso que se chama problema OR.
Outro exemplo é o problema de paridade, que é semelhante ao problema OR, exceto que pede a paridade,
ou em outras palavras, o OU eXclusivo de todos os valores de saída de bit único
da função.
Outra forma de dizer isso é
que a resposta correta é 0 se o número de strings de n bits x para as quais f de x é igual a 1 é par,
e a resposta correta é
1 se esse número for ímpar.
Um exemplo de um problema onde m não é necessariamente igual a 1 é o problema do mínimo.
Aqui, a função f tem a forma usual, e não há restrições em n e m,
e a resposta correta é qualquer valor de saída
da função que venha primeiro na ordenação lexicográfica
ou de dicionário
de strings binárias. Alternativamente, se você quiser
pensar em strings de comprimento m como representando inteiros não negativos
em notação binária,
então a resposta correta
é o menor valor possível, ou mínimo, que
sai dessa função.
Às vezes também consideramos problemas de consulta onde temos uma promessa
sobre a função de entrada, ou em outras palavras, algum
tipo de garantia sobre ela,
e não nos preocupamos com funções que não atendem essa promessa.
Funções que não satisfazem a promessa são consideradas entradas "não me importa".
E simplesmente não somos responsáveis pelo que acontece com essas entradas.
Aqui está um exemplo de um problema de consulta com promessa chamado busca única.
Ele está relacionado ao problema OR,
mas é diferente.
A função de entrada tem a mesma
forma do problema OR, que é que ela mapeia
strings de n bits para bits.
Desta vez, é prometido que
existe exatamente uma string Z que faz f avaliar para 1,
com f de x sendo igual a 0
para toda string x diferente de z, e a saída correta
é essa string única z.
Claro, existem
escolhas para a função f que não satisfazem essa condição, mas não colocamos nenhum requisito
nos algoritmos para este problema quando são dadas tais
funções como entrada.
Só nos importamos com as funções que satisfazem a promessa.
Agora, todos os quatro
problemas que mencionei são problemas bem naturais, no sentido de que é fácil explicá-los,
e é fácil imaginar situações em que a necessidade de resolvê-los pode surgir, mas alguns problemas de consulta
não são assim.
Na verdade, às vezes consideramos problemas de consulta altamente
artificiais, onde é difícil imaginar que alguém
realmente queira resolvê-los.
O problema de Simon, que veremos
mais adiante na aula, cai um pouco nessa categoria, mas existem outros
que são muito piores em algum sentido, mas que, no entanto, acabam sendo bem importantes para o estudo do modelo de consulta.
Não estudamos esses problemas porque necessariamente queremos
resolvê-los na prática.
A forma de pensar sobre isso é que estamos procurando por
extremos de vários tipos,
em particular, quando estamos trabalhando dentro desta
placa de Petri de um modelo, uma forma natural de explorar
ideias algorítmicas quânticas
é formular problemas altamente artificiais, onde podemos melhor explorar o
poder dos computadores quânticos.
E isso pode
lançar muita luz sobre como os computadores quânticos
podem ser úteis em ambientes mais práticos.
Podemos formalizar a noção
de uma consulta de diferentes maneiras dependendo de qual modelo computacional
estamos trabalhando.
Por exemplo, no modelo de máquina de
Turing de computação, que não falamos e não entraremos nesta série,
existe uma certa maneira de
formalizar a noção de uma consulta que faz sentido para aquele modelo.
Para modelos de circuit, definimos tipos especiais de
gates chamados query gates, e é assim que as consultas
são formalmente representadas.
Para circuits Booleanos, existe uma maneira muito simples de fazer isso, que é simplesmente imaginar
que temos query gates
que avaliam a função de entrada diretamente, como você pode ver aqui na tela.
A ideia é que podemos
usar esses query gates para construir circuits que resolvem qualquer
problema que estejamos analisando,
e para funcionar corretamente, os circuits devem dar a resposta certa para qualquer função de entrada f fornecida,
assumindo que ela atende à promessa no caso de um problema com promessa.
Aqui está um exemplo simples
de um circuit Booleano que resolve o problema de paridade quando n é igual a 1,
então a função de entrada f vai
de 1 bit para 1 bit neste caso.
O que este circuit faz é avaliar a função
f nas entradas 0 e 1 usando esses dois query gates.
Em seguida, ele conecta os dois valores de saída obtidos
dos query gates ao circuit Booleano da aula três que calcula o XOR,
que é a mesma coisa que a paridade.
Para ficar claro, esses dois
valores de entrada aqui não são entradas para o problema,
ou seja, o problema de paridade,
quando estamos trabalhando com o modelo de consulta, a entrada para o problema
é a função f, e você deve pensar nesses
dois valores de entrada no circuit
como valores fixos
que nunca mudam, eles são essencialmente parte do algoritmo.
Queremos calcular o XOR de f 0 e f 1, então inicializamos esses
dois fios dessa forma
para fazer funcionar. Usamos dois query gates
aqui, este e aquele,
e então o algoritmo representado
por este circuit Booleano faz duas consultas, e se pensarmos sobre o
problema de paridade por um momento
para funções de um bit para um bit, vemos que é absolutamente necessário para qualquer circuit Booleano
que resolva este problema
fazer pelo menos duas consultas.
Se você fizer apenas uma consulta, de modo que saiba apenas um
valor de saída da função f e não o outro, você não tem
nenhuma informação
sobre a paridade, porque o outro valor de saída
poderia muito bem ser 0 ou 1, levando a qualquer uma das
duas soluções possíveis
para o problema. Então, em termos do número
de consultas que ele faz, este circuit Booleano é o melhor possível
para o problema de paridade
quando n é igual a 1.
Há mais um ponto sobre os query gates que vale mencionar antes de continuar, e é que quando estamos projetando e analisando algoritmos de consulta,
não nos preocupamos nada com como
os query gates são implementados.
Assume-se que esses
query gates nos são fornecidos, e a dificuldade de construí-los não é nossa preocupação.
Você pode pensar nos
query gates em si como sendo a entrada, se quiser, e não é nosso trabalho criar a entrada, estamos apenas tentando
resolver um problema específico
dada a entrada. Claro, quando f é uma função
de um bit para um bit, há apenas quatro escolhas possíveis,
e seria fácil o suficiente
implementar qualquer uma delas, mas em geral, para funções
com muitos bits de entrada,
pode ser extremamente difícil implementar query gates
para essas funções.
Para ficar claro, isso não quer
dizer que a questão de como os query gates são
implementados não é importante, mas sim que isso não é considerado
parte do custo
de um algoritmo de consulta.
Isso é consistente com a ideia de que isso não é realmente
sobre computação prática ou construção real de circuits,
mas sobre trabalhar dentro
de um framework teórico que nos conta coisas interessantes
sobre computação.
Teremos mais a dizer sobre isso quando fizermos a transição deste modelo para um modelo de computação mais padrão, e é principalmente sobre isso que a próxima aula,
a Aula 6, tratará.
Agora vamos voltar a atenção
para os quantum circuits.
Para quantum circuits, vamos mudar a
definição dos query gates para torná-los unitários.
Queremos ser capazes de fazer
consultas dentro de quantum circuits e que eles operem
linearmente nos estados quânticos
para que possamos efetivamente
fazer consultas em superposição.
Pode parecer que estamos
movendo os postes, por assim dizer, ao mudar o que queremos dizer com uma consulta em comparação ao que acabamos
de ver para circuits Booleanos,
mas há justificativa para isso, que discutiremos com mais
detalhes na próxima aula.
Por ora, é apenas uma definição.
Especificamente, a
definição é a seguinte: dada qualquer função f da
mesma forma de antes,
ou seja, que mapeia strings de n bits
para strings de m bits, o query gate Uf age sobre n + m qubits
e é definido pela
ação descrita aqui nos estados da base padrão.
Vamos ver uma figura
representando essa definição em instantes, mas primeiro, deixa eu esclarecer a notação
que está sendo usada aqui,
que é: sempre que
usamos o símbolo do XOR como uma operação entre duas
strings do mesmo comprimento,
estamos nos referindo ao
OU eXclusivo bit a bit, e aqui você pode ver um exemplo.
Na definição, temos que tanto y quanto f de
x são strings de comprimento m, então essa string aqui
representa a string que obtemos
fazendo XOR dessas duas strings
juntas, um bit por vez, e aqui está o diagrama
que explica como esses gates funcionam.
Os n qubits de cima correspondem ao
argumento da função.
E quando começam
em um estado da base padrão, cat x neste diagrama, esse estado da base padrão
passa inalterado
e é ecoado como parte da saída.
Os m qubits de baixo correspondem à saída
da função f, e quando começam em
qualquer estado da base padrão,
cat y neste diagrama, o que acontece é que a
saída da função f de x é aplicada com XOR na string y.
É isso que acontece para
estados da base padrão, e se quisermos saber
o que acontece em geral para outros estados quânticos, usamos
a linearidade, como sempre fazemos.
Uma razão para definir query gates assim, onde ecoamos a entrada e usamos o XOR bit a bit para a saída,
é que esses gates são sempre unitários para qualquer escolha da função f.
Esta é, de fato, uma
operação determinística.
E se fôssemos expressá-la como uma matriz para qualquer escolha de uma função F, obteríamos uma matriz de permutação,
ou seja, uma com um único um em cada linha e em cada coluna, e todas as outras entradas iguais a 0.
E matrizes de permutação
são sempre unitárias.
Na verdade, para esta operação, vamos descobrir que a operação
é sua própria inversa, então Uf dagger é igual a Uf.
Se tudo que queremos fazer com esses
gates é avaliar f de x para alguma string x, isso é fácil,
podemos simplesmente definir y como
a string de todos zeros. Então quando fazemos o OU eXclusivo dos bits y, acabamos apenas com f de x.
Aqui, aliás, você pode ver a notação usada para denotar a string de todos zeros.
Parece 0 elevado à potência M, mas não é isso que significa.
Significa a string de zeros
com comprimento igual a M.
Quando estamos falando sobre
strings em vez de números, expoentes tipicamente significam que repetimos aquela string
um certo número de vezes,
então isso é 0 repetido m vezes.
É apenas uma forma conveniente e precisa de descrever essa string.
Mais uma vez, quando estamos
trabalhando com o modelo de consulta, não estamos nos preocupando em como
implementar esses query gates.
É o mesmo problema
que tínhamos com query gates para circuit Booleano.
Não é nosso trabalho preparar a entrada, a entrada nos é fornecida na
forma desses query gates.
Devo apontar, porém, que se soubermos como
implementar a função f usando um circuit Booleano, então é possível
traduzir essa implementação
de forma bastante direta para uma
implementação em quantum circuit do Uf, e vamos ver exatamente como
isso funciona na próxima aula.
Como observação, é bastante simples criar um circuit Booleano
que funcione assim, usando um único
query gate clássico para a função f,
mas isso é bem diferente de ter uma
implementação em quantum circuit desse gate unitário.
O ponto, porém, é que
para algoritmos de consulta clássicos, ter um query gate que funcione assim é, de fato, equivalente
a ter um
query gate clássico ordinário para f, no sentido de que qualquer um pode ser implementado usando o outro.
Nesta seção da aula, vamos discutir o algoritmo de Deutsch, que é um algoritmo
de consulta quântica muito simples, mas é realmente uma joia.
Este algoritmo vem de um artigo de 1985 escrito por David Deutsch, que foi uma das primeiras pessoas a trabalhar nos fundamentos teóricos
da computação quântica.
O algoritmo em si representa uma parte muito pequena
do artigo de 1985 de Deutsch, e na verdade,
o algoritmo que hoje
chamamos de algoritmo de Deutsch é na verdade uma versão melhorada do algoritmo que Deutsch descreveu.
Ele fornece um exemplo bem modesto de como os computadores quânticos podem
oferecer vantagens computacionais, mas é preciso começar em algum lugar,
e foi realmente uma faísca importante que deu início às coisas.
O algoritmo de Deutsch resolve um problema de consulta que é muitas vezes chamado de problema de Deutsch no contexto da computação quântica,
mas na verdade, não é nada mais
do que o problema de paridade para funções de um bit para um bit, sobre o qual já falamos.
Como já vimos, há quatro funções
de um bit para um bit, e elas são descritas aqui na tela por suas tabelas de valores.
A primeira e a última dessas
funções são constantes, enquanto as duas do meio são balanceadas, no sentido de que os dois
valores de saída possíveis
aparecem o mesmo número de vezes.
Para as duas funções constantes,
vemos que a paridade, ou em outras palavras, o OU eXclusivo das duas saídas é 0,
e para as duas funções balanceadas, a paridade das saídas é 1.
Então uma forma equivalente de
descrever o problema de paridade neste caso específico, onde a função f recebe
um único bit como entrada,
ou em outras palavras, o problema de Deutsch, é como você vê aqui.
A entrada é uma função f
de um bit para um bit, e a saída é 0 se f é constante
e 1 se f é balanceada.
Como já sugeri, todo algoritmo de consulta clássico
que resolve este problema deve fazer pelo menos duas consultas a f.
Se você aprende apenas um dos
dois valores de saída de f, você ainda não tem nenhuma informação sobre a paridade das duas saídas.
E isso, aliás, é verdadeiro
mesmo para algoritmos clássicos que fazem uso de aleatoriedade.
A aleatoriedade às vezes pode ser muito útil para resolver problemas de consulta, e vamos ver um exemplo
um pouco mais adiante na aula,
mas a aleatoriedade não ajuda aqui.
Então nosso algoritmo anterior é ótimo entre os algoritmos de consulta clássicos
para o problema de Deutsch.
Agora vamos dar uma olhada
no algoritmo de Deutsch, que é um algoritmo de consulta quântica que resolve o problema de Deutsch
usando uma única consulta.
E aqui está o algoritmo
descrito como um quantum circuit.
Temos dois qubits
inicializados como você vê aqui, com o de cima inicializado para cat 0 e o de baixo inicializado para cat 1,
e vamos ver por que inicializamos esses qubits assim em breve.
Realizamos gates Hadamard
nos dois qubits, os alimentamos no query gate, realizamos outro gate Hadamard
no qubit de cima,
e então medimos. E a afirmação é que
o resultado da medição nos dá, com certeza, a
resposta correta para o problema.
Então vamos analisar o
circuit passo a passo para ver exatamente como ele funciona.
O estado dos dois qubits após a primeira camada de gates Hadamard é o produto tensorial dos
estados menos e mais.
O Hadamard de cima mapeia
o estado 0 para um estado mais, e o Hadamard de baixo mapeia o estado 1 para um estado menos.
O qubit de cima está à direita, e o qubit de baixo está à esquerda, então este é o estado que obtemos.
É muito importante que o qubit de baixo esteja no estado menos, aliás, isso não funcionaria se
inicializarmos o qubit de baixo
para o estado 0 em vez do estado 1.
Vamos expandir esse estado
pela metade, como você vê aqui.
A razão para fazer isso
não está clara neste momento, mas será conveniente
daqui a pouco.
A seguir, vamos pensar sobre
o estado dos dois qubits após o query gate ser realizado.
A forma como o query gate
funciona é que ele computa F no estado da base padrão do qubit de cima e aplica XOR do valor
no qubit de baixo,
e aqui podemos ver o
resultado de fazer isso.
Para o primeiro termo, o estado da base padrão
do qubit de cima é 0, então f de zero é aplicado com XOR
no qubit de baixo,
e isso funciona por linearidade. E é similar para o segundo termo, exceto que o estado da base padrão
para o qubit de cima é 1, então aplicamos XOR de f de 1 no qubit de baixo.
E neste ponto, podemos
simplificar esta expressão observando a fórmula
que você pode ver aqui embaixo, que funciona quando a é 0 ou 1.
E podemos simplesmente verificar isso para esses dois valores separadamente.
Se a é igual a 0, então
aplicar XOR com a não faz nada, e negativo 1 elevado à potência 0 é 1,
então os dois lados são iguais. E se a é igual a 1, obtemos cat 1 menos cat
0 quando fazemos o XOR,
que é negativo 1
vezes cat 0 menos cat 1.
E se usarmos essa fórmula
para simplificar nosso estado, onde tomamos a igual
a f de 0 à esquerda e a igual a f de 1 à direita,
obtemos a expressão
que você vê aqui.
Então quando comparamos os dois
vetores de estado quântico π1 e π2, vemos que o que o gate Uf faz
é efetivamente colocar
um dos dois valores, f de 0 ou f de 1, no
expoente de negativo 1,
ou em outras palavras,
na fase de cada termo.
Esta é a razão de
inicializar o qubit de baixo para 1 e realizar um gate Hadamard nele para criar o estado menos,
o que permite que isso aconteça.
É chamado de fenômeno de phase kickback, e voltaremos a ele daqui a pouco para ter outra olhada.
É bem importante, e vamos vê-lo acontecendo
mais algumas vezes na aula, assim como em aulas posteriores.
Agora podemos simplificar trazendo
o estado menos de volta para fora para obter a expressão
que você vê aqui.
A propósito, é
interessante notar que não há na verdade
nenhum entrelaçamento aqui.
Ambos esses estados são estados produto. Então, bem, o entrelaçamento
é extremamente interessante,
não está desempenhando
nenhum papel neste algoritmo específico.
Vamos limpar um pouco para termos um pouco mais de espaço.
O que podemos fazer agora é
extrair um fator de negativo 1 elevado à potência f de zero
para obter a expressão do
estado que você vê aqui.
Você vai notar que aqui, temos o OU eXclusivo de f 0 e f 1 no expoente de negativo 1.
Poderíamos esperar que fosse
f de 1 menos f de 0 porque extraímos o fator de negativo 1 elevado a f de 0,
mas obtemos o mesmo
valor se tomarmos o XOR porque esses são bits, e a única coisa que importa quando temos um inteiro no
expoente de negativo 1
é se esse inteiro é par ou ímpar.
Outra forma de expressar este
estado é como temos aqui, onde estamos apenas considerando
os dois casos possíveis para o XOR.
e essa é uma forma conveniente
de expressar o estado ao considerarmos a ação
do gate Hadamard final juntamente com a medição.
Quando realizamos o último
gate Hadamard no qubit de cima, o estado mais é
transformado em um estado 0
e o estado menos é
transformado em um estado 1, o que podemos escrever de forma mais
sucinta assim.
E finalmente, quando a
medição é realizada, o resultado que obtemos é
portanto o XOR de f 0 e f 1,
que é o valor que estávamos procurando, e é assim que o algoritmo de Deutsch funciona.
É bem simples, e se nos perguntarmos o que
é que faz funcionar, permitindo-nos calcular
a paridade de dois bits
com uma única consulta em vez de duas, uma resposta razoável é
que é a interferência.
Estamos efetivamente
computando f de 0 e f de 1 ao mesmo tempo, porque primeiro realizamos
o gate Hadamard
no qubit de cima para colocar a entrada de f em
uma superposição de 0 e 1.
E por meio do phase kickback junto com o gate Hadamard final, estamos essencialmente criando
interferência construtiva
para a resposta correta e interferência destrutiva
para a resposta errada.
Então não vemos a resposta errada, vemos apenas a resposta correta.
Deixa eu dizer um pouco mais sobre o fenômeno de phase kickback apenas para vê-lo de um
ângulo ligeiramente diferente.
Primeiro, vamos observar
esta fórmula muito simples onde b e c são valores binários arbitrários.
Em resumo, aplicar XOR a um bit b pelo valor 1 é a mesma coisa que realizar um gate NOT ou uma operação x em b,
e claro, aplicar XOR
a um bit b pelo valor 0 não faz nada com ele, que é a mesma coisa que realizar a
operação de identidade nele.
E podemos expressar a operação de identidade como x elevado à potência 0.
Então se realizamos um gate Uf em dois qubits no estado da base padrão cat b tensor cat a,
obtemos esse resultado, apenas pela definição do gate Uf.
e usando a fórmula, podemos alternativamente escrever esse estado como você vê aqui.
Esta fórmula funciona para todas as escolhas de b, então por linearidade, funciona
para um estado SI arbitrário
no lugar de cat b.
E em particular, se quisermos, podemos escolher SI como sendo o estado menos.
E agora aqui está a chave para entender por que o fenômeno de phase kickback
acontece.
É porque a operação x
aplicada ao estado menos nos dá negativo 1 vezes o estado menos.
Em termos matemáticos, dizemos que o estado menos
é um autovetor da operação x, com autovalor igual a negativo 1.
Autovetores e autovalores
são criticamente importantes em álgebra linear assim como
na informação quântica, e teremos muito
mais a dizer sobre eles
conforme a série continua.
Mas por ora, tudo que precisamos
é dessa fórmula simples.
E usando ela, podemos
simplificar nosso vetor de estado.
E isso aí é essencialmente o fenômeno de phase kickback
escrito como uma fórmula.
Funciona porque o estado menos
é um autovetor da operação NOT com
autovalor negativo um.
Vamos generalizar isso de uma forma
bastante significativa na Aula 7, quando passarmos para o procedimento de estimativa de fase, que é o que impulsiona
o algoritmo de fatoração de Shor.
Podemos ver essa fórmula em ação na análise do algoritmo de Deutsch
da seguinte forma.
Antes do query gate, nosso estado é o produto tensorial dos estados menos e mais.
Em seguida aplicamos o query gate, e expandir o estado mais
nos dá este estado.
Agora aplicamos a fórmula de phase kickback para obter esta expressão, e então a análise
continua como antes.
É a mesma de antes, mas aqui estamos apenas colocando
o foco no phase kickback para que possamos reconhecê-lo
e também estarmos prontos para ele
quando surgir novamente.
A seguir, vamos passar para o
algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa, que é uma extensão
do algoritmo de Deutsch que na verdade resolve alguns
problemas de consulta diferentes.
A vantagem que
o algoritmo de Deutsch fornece sobre os algoritmos clássicos
é bem modesta, uma consulta versus duas.
O algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa aumenta um pouco essa vantagem, e vou explicar o que quero
dizer com isso quando chegarmos lá.
O algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa pode ser visto como uma forma natural e direta de estender o algoritmo de Deutsch
de funções de um bit para um bit para funções de n bits para um bit, ou em outras palavras, funções desta forma.
Como um quantum circuit, o algoritmo
Deutsch-Jozsa se parece com isso, e vou me referir a isso
como o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
apenas para fazer uma distinção menor
entre este circuit e o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa em si, porque há também uma
etapa de pós-processamento clássico.
A ideia é que se executarmos
este circuit e então medirmos, obteremos alguma string de n bits y
que nos diz algo
sobre a função f.
A propósito, neste ponto, ainda não disse
qual é o problema de consulta que esperamos
resolver com este circuit, isso vem muito em breve.
Mas o ponto é que
ao executar este circuit, vamos ganhar alguma informação sobre f que pode potencialmente nos ajudar
a resolver problemas de consulta
onde f é a entrada. E como disse há pouco, podemos na verdade usar este circuit
para resolver alguns
problemas de consulta diferentes.
Primeiro, vamos dar uma olhada
no problema de consulta conhecido como o problema Deutsch-Jozsa, que é o problema que
o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
foi originalmente pensado para resolver.
O problema Deutsch-Jozsa é uma generalização do problema de Deutsch, onde o objetivo é determinar se uma dada função
é constante ou balanceada.
Observe que esta não é a forma natural de generalizar o problema de paridade
para funções desta forma.
Aqui não estamos calculando a paridade, a tarefa é retornar 0 se
a função f é constante
e 1 se a função f é balanceada.
A primeira coisa a notar sobre
este problema é que quando n, o número de bits de entrada para
a função f, é pelo menos 2,
há escolhas para a função que não são nem constantes nem balanceadas.
Por exemplo, aqui está uma
função de 2 bits para 1 bit que não é nem constante nem balanceada.
Não é constante porque ambos os valores binários
aparecem entre as saídas, e não é balanceada
porque os dois valores de saída
aparecem com frequências diferentes. 0 aparece três vezes
e 1 aparece apenas uma vez.
Para ser balanceada,
as saídas 0 e 1 devem ocorrer exatamente
o mesmo número de vezes.
O fato de que existem funções que não são nem constantes nem balanceadas quando n é pelo menos 2 não é problema, porém, vamos apenas considerar
funções assim
como entradas "não me importa". Então em outras palavras, isso
é um problema com promessa.
E aqui está um enunciado preciso
do problema.
É prometido que a função de entrada f é constante ou balanceada, e o objetivo é descobrir
qual delas é.
E não somos responsáveis pelo que acontece se a entrada
não atender à promessa.
O algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa,
que resolve este problema, consiste primeiro em executar o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa e então retornar 0
se a string que
obtemos das medições é a string de todos zeros
e retornar 1 caso contrário.
Outra forma de dizer isso é que retornamos o OR dos
bits que medimos.
Para analisar o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa, vai ser útil
primeiro dedicar alguns momentos para pensar sobre gates Hadamard.
Podemos, claro, descrever a operação Hadamard
como uma matriz, mas também podemos descrevê-la em termos de sua ação
nos estados da base padrão,
como você vê aqui.
Essas duas equações podem ser
combinadas em uma única equação, que descreve como uma operação Hadamard funciona para a sendo qualquer um dos
dois valores binários,
e podemos ir um pouco mais longe e expressar o que
obtemos como uma soma assim.
Usando aquela fórmula, podemos criar uma fórmula que descreve como uma camada
de gates Hadamard funciona, onde aplicamos um gate Hadamard
para cada um dos n qubits.
Aqui estamos descrevendo essa
ação nos estados da base padrão.
E para ficar claro sobre a notação, quando escrevemos h tensor n assim, onde a parte tensor n é um sobrescrito,
queremos dizer o produto tensorial
de n vezes de H consigo mesmo, ou em outras palavras, n cópias
de h todos tensorados juntos.
Estamos aplicando esta operação
a um estado da base padrão, e aqui estou seguindo a
convenção que Qiskit usa
para indexar strings binárias, simplesmente porque é um bom momento
para introduzir essa convenção.
Então x0 é um bit, x1 é um bit,
e assim por diante com n bits no total, e os bits são ordenados como
você vê aqui na tela.
Você pode pensar nessa
forma de indexar bits como correspondendo à sua significância se visualizarmos strings como
representando inteiros
em notação binária, por exemplo.
Se aplicarmos um gate Hadamard
a cada um desses qubits, podemos alternativamente expressar o resultado como o produto tensorial de n vezes
de um gate Hadamard aplicado a cada qubit, e então podemos aplicar nossa fórmula a cada um dos fatores tensoriais.
E aqui estamos usando os
nomes y e menos 1 até y1 no lugar de b na fórmula,
então esses são valores binários. E estamos garantindo usar um nome novo cada vez que usamos a fórmula.
Se expandirmos tudo usando a multilinearidade
dos produtos tensoriais, obtemos a expressão
que você vê aqui.
E para ficar claro, as n somas estão sendo
combinadas em uma única soma, mas ainda estamos somando
sobre todos os valores possíveis
para os valores binários individuais.
Agora vamos simplificar para poder ir um pouco mais longe.
E o próximo passo é
introduzir uma nova operação em strings chamada produto escalar binário.
Esta é uma operação em strings binárias do mesmo comprimento.
E o que o produto escalar binário de duas strings x e y
do mesmo comprimento é, é o OU eXclusivo ou a paridade
dos produtos dos bits individuais.
Você também poderia dizer que é o XOR do AND lógico dos bits individuais, porque o AND é a
mesma coisa que o produto
para valores binários. Ainda outra forma de descrever
é que é 1 ou 0
dependendo de
se a soma dos produtos dos bits individuais é ímpar ou par.
É muito parecido com um produto interno se pensarmos em strings
como vetores de valores binários, mas onde calculamos módulo-2,
ou em outras palavras, tomamos o resto após dividir por 2.
Mas não é realmente um produto interno, então merece um nome diferente.
No caso em questão, podemos usar o produto escalar binário
para tornar nossa fórmula para a ação de uma camada de gates Hadamard
nos estados da base padrão mais sucinta, e aqui está.
Estamos usando o fato de que
porque esta soma aqui está aparecendo no
expoente de negativo 1,
o que importa é
se ela é par ou ímpar, mas fora isso, é basicamente apenas uma versão condensada
da nossa fórmula.
Aliás, o produto escalar binário
é simétrico no sentido de que x ponto
y e y ponto x são iguais,
então somos livres para trocar a
ordenação sempre que isso for útil.
E agora que temos essa fórmula, será bem fácil analisar
o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Começamos com n qubits no estado 0 e o qubit de baixo no estado 1, e realizamos gates Hadamard
em todos eles.
Então este é o estado dos
n + 1 qubits que obtemos.
Estamos tratando o
qubit de baixo separadamente porque isso vai ser conveniente.
E novamente, vamos ver o fenômeno de phase kickback
acontecendo.
Podemos obter esta expressão
usando nossa fórmula, onde substituímos a
string de todos zeros por x e substituímos x por y,
observando que o produto escalar binário da string de todos zeros com qualquer string é 0.
Mas também podemos simplesmente raciocinar isso diretamente. Estamos tomando o produto tensorial de n estados mais, e é isso que obtemos,
tensorado com o estado menos. Em seguida o gate UF é aplicado, e é aqui que o fenômeno de phase kickback
acontece.
O valor f de x está sendo
aplicado com XOR no estado menos para cada x na soma.
Então f de x é "chutado" para a fase.
Agora aplicamos outra
camada de gates Hadamard apenas nos n qubits de cima, e desta vez, realmente
precisamos da fórmula.
E quando a aplicamos e fazemos uma pequena
simplificação, obtemos este estado aqui.
Então esse é nosso estado final, logo
antes das medições.
O estado parece um pouco complicado, e é difícil simplificá-lo porque não sabemos realmente
nada sobre a função f.
Mas lembre-se que tudo
que realmente precisamos saber é se as medições
resultam todas no resultado 0 ou não,
porque é isso que determina qual é nossa resposta para o problema.
Se vemos que todo
resultado de medição é 0, concluímos que a função é constante.
E se qualquer um dos
resultados de medição é 1, concluímos que a função é balanceada.
Então vamos calcular a probabilidade de obter a string de todos zeros
das medições.
E isso acaba sendo o único resultado que é realmente fácil de calcular, porque o produto escalar binário da string de todos zeros
com qualquer string é zero. Se examinarmos nosso vetor e
pensarmos sobre o que acontece quando y é a string de todos zeros,
obtemos esta expressão
para a probabilidade de obter a string de todos zeros
das medições.
E considerando os dois casos possíveis onde f é constante e f é balanceada, vemos que a probabilidade de
obter a string de todos zeros é 1
no caso em que f é constante, e zero quando f é balanceada.
Quando f é constante, a soma é 2 elevado a
n ou negativo 2 elevado a n, e dividindo por dois elevado a n
e tomando o valor absoluto
ao quadrado resulta em 1.
E quando f é balanceada, a soma é igual a 0.
Isso é porque teremos
positivo 1 e negativo 1 um número igual de vezes,
então todos se cancelam.
É isso. O algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa
resolve o problema Deutsch-Jozsa usando uma única consulta,
e não há erro. Assumindo que as operações
são todas feitas perfeitamente, está correto em todas as vezes.
Então como isso se compara com
o que podemos fazer classicamente?
Bem, se insistirmos em um
algoritmo determinístico que obtém a resposta
correta todas as vezes, então, no pior caso,
precisamos de 2 elevado a n menos 1 mais 1 consultas, e isso é porque temos que consultar a função
em mais da metade de suas entradas para ter certeza sobre a solução.
Mesmo se consultarmos a função em 2 elevado a n menos 1
strings de entrada diferentes, é possível que vejamos o mesmo valor de saída
toda vez, e isso poderia ser porque
a função é constante, ou poderia ser que ela é na verdade balanceada
e tivemos um azar incrível ao ter visto o mesmo valor de saída
toda vez.
Então essa é uma enorme vantagem
do quântico sobre o clássico, uma única consulta versus
exponencialmente muitas consultas.
No entanto, se usarmos um
algoritmo de consulta probabilístico e aceitarmos uma pequena probabilidade de resposta incorreta,
então na verdade só precisamos de algumas consultas.
Em particular, se
escolhermos aleatoriamente k strings e avaliarmos a função
nessas strings aleatórias,
então é bem provável que possamos descobrir a resposta certa.
Especificamente, respondemos 0 ou constante quando obtemos o mesmo valor de função toda vez e 1 ou balanceada
sempre que vemos dois
valores de função diferentes.
Se fizermos isso, estaremos sempre corretos quando
a função é constante porque, claro, sempre veremos o mesmo
valor de saída neste caso.
E se f é balanceada, é muito provável que vejamos
dois valores de saída diferentes.
A chance de não vermos
ambos os valores de saída neste caso é a mesma que a chance que temos de lançar uma moeda k vezes
e obter o mesmo
resultado toda vez.
Por exemplo, se
definirmos k igual a 11, a probabilidade de obter uma resposta errada é menor que um décimo de um por cento.
Então, especialmente quando consideramos o fato de que os computadores quânticos nunca serão perfeitos na realidade, não obtemos uma vantagem tão
grande aqui,
mas estamos progredindo, e temos uma vantagem quantificável do quântico sobre o clássico que vai além do algoritmo de Deutsch.
Também podemos usar o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa para resolver um problema de consulta diferente conhecido como o problema Bernstein-Vazirani.
Aqui está um enunciado desse problema. A entrada é uma função
de n bits para 1 bit, assim como o problema Deutsch-Jozsa,
e novamente, é um problema com promessa.
Desta vez, a promessa é que existe alguma string de n bits s para a qual a função f
funciona como você vê aqui,
onde a saída é dada
pelo produto escalar binário da entrada com esta string s,
e o objetivo é simplesmente
encontrar a string s. Então podemos imaginar que a
string s está oculta de algum forma,
mas podemos aprender sobre ela
fazendo consultas a f, e nosso objetivo é encontrar
essa string oculta.
Para ficar claro, a maioria das funções
não vai satisfazer esta promessa, mas como de costume, só nos importamos com as
funções de entrada que satisfazem.
Como se verifica, o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa na verdade resolve este problema
direto de cara.
Se o executarmos para uma
função como temos aqui que satisfaz a
promessa para alguma string s, as medições vão revelar a string s
sem nenhum pós-processamento necessário.
Então vamos ver como isso funciona.
Já analisamos
o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, então podemos
ir direto ao final.
Aqui está a expressão que
tínhamos antes para o estado logo antes das medições, e essa expressão era
válida para qualquer função f.
E agora, se substituirmos
o que é prometido sobre a função f e simplificarmos,
obtemos o estado menos
para o qubit de baixo tensorado com cat s para os n qubits de cima.
E então obtemos s quando medimos.
Existe algum trabalho a ser feito para realizar as simplificações
que mostrei aqui, e não vou passar por isso neste vídeo,
mas há mais detalhes sobre isso no conteúdo do livro didático para esta série, que você pode encontrar seguindo o link na descrição do vídeo,
ou apenas tente você mesmo
para praticar.
Então o que descobrimos é que
o circuit Deutsch-Jozsa resolve o problema
Bernstein-Vazirani com uma única consulta.
Não é difícil demais mostrar
que qualquer algoritmo clássico, seja ele determinístico
ou probabilístico, precisa de pelo menos n consultas
para resolver o problema Bernstein-Vazirani pela simples razão de que precisamos de n bits de
informação para recuperar s,
e cada consulta nos dá no
máximo 1 bit de informação.
Então obtemos outra vantagem do quântico sobre os algoritmos de consulta clássicos, uma consulta para algoritmos quânticos,
n consultas para algoritmos clássicos.
Vale a pena dedicar um momento para falar sobre a
nomenclatura usada no contexto deste problema e um pouco sobre a história.
As pessoas às vezes se referem ao algoritmo que acabei de descrever como sendo o algoritmo Bernstein-Vazirani, mas é realmente apenas o
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa,
e isso é algo que foi,
de fato, claramente declarado no trabalho de Bernstein e Vazirani.
Então é um pouco estranho que seja chamado de algoritmo
Bernstein-Vazirani porque é praticamente a mesma coisa que o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa
menos o pós-processamento. Bernstein e Vazirani,
no entanto, foram um passo além.
Eles definiram uma versão
recursiva deste problema, onde você basicamente
tem que resolver instâncias do problema Bernstein-Vazirani
para desbloquear novas instâncias do problema que estão organizadas em um
padrão complicado semelhante a uma árvore.
É um problema altamente artificial, mas o ponto é que ao
definir um problema desta forma, eles poderiam efetivamente esticar
a separação de uma versus n consultas entre o quântico e o clássico.
E o que eles obtiveram é
o primeiro exemplo conhecido de uma chamada vantagem super polinomial do quântico sobre algoritmos probabilísticos.
Esta versão recursiva do
problema Bernstein-Vazirani também acabou sendo muito interessante, muito mais tarde, na teoria da complexidade computacional por razões diferentes.
De qualquer forma, o ponto é que
Bernstein e Vazirani certamente merecem reconhecimento por suas importantes contribuições,
mas realmente não faz
sentido referir-se a isso como o algoritmo Bernstein-Vazirani, é basicamente apenas o
algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa.
Na última parte da aula, vamos dar uma olhada em mais um
algoritmo de consulta quântica conhecido como o algoritmo de Simon.
Você verá uma clara semelhança
entre este algoritmo e o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa, mas ele é diferente, e mais importante,
ele revela uma vantagem muito maior do quântico sobre os algoritmos de consulta
clássicos.
Especificamente, nos dá uma
vantagem exponencial comprovável do quântico sobre os algoritmos clássicos, até mesmo os probabilísticos.
O problema que ele resolve é um pouco artificial, e é difícil imaginar uma situação em que resolver este
problema seria útil,
mas inspirou diretamente
a descoberta por Peter Shor de um algoritmo quântico
para fatoração de inteiros,
e isso apoia fortemente
essa ideia do modelo de consulta como uma placa de Petri na qual ideias algoritmos
quânticos podem ser desenvolvidas.
Vamos começar com o problema de consulta que o algoritmo de Simon resolve, que, como você pode ter adivinhado,
é chamado de problema de Simon.
Aqui está um enunciado do problema, e precisamos desempacotá-lo para entender do que se trata.
A primeira coisa a
notar é que desta vez, a função de entrada f mapeia strings de n
bits para strings de m bits
onde m é algum inteiro positivo que não é igual a um em geral.
É um problema com promessa. E como o problema Bernstein-Vazirani, a promessa envolve alguma string s que podemos ver como uma string oculta,
e também como o
problema Bernstein-Vazirani, o objetivo é retornar
essa string oculta s.
A promessa é mais
complicada desta vez, então vamos desmontá-la e
entender o que ela está dizendo.
Para começar, vamos apenas lê-la. Ela diz que existe uma string s de comprimento igual a n
tal que uma condição de "se"
e "somente se" específica é verdadeira para todas as escolhas de strings de n bits x e y.
Especificamente, deve
ser o caso que f de x é igual a f de y se e somente se uma de
duas possibilidades vale.
A primeira possibilidade é que x é igual a y, e a segunda possibilidade é que ao tomar o OU eXclusivo bit a bit de x
com a string oculta s, obtemos Y.
Isso acaba sendo uma
promessa bastante rígida no sentido de que a maioria
das funções não vai satisfazê-la.
Apenas funções muito especiais
satisfazem esta condição.
Agora, para ter uma melhor compreensão desta promessa e, portanto, do próprio problema, vamos considerar dois casos principais.
O primeiro caso é que s
é a string de todos zeros.
Neste caso, podemos simplificar a declaração de "se"
e "somente se" na promessa porque o OU eXclusivo bit a bit de qualquer string x
com a string de todos zeros
é simplesmente a string x.
Então a condição se simplifica
para f de x é igual a f de y se e somente se x é igual a y.
E isso é apenas outra maneira de dizer que f é uma função bijetora.
Em outras palavras, a string f de x deve ser única
para cada string x possível.
Então se f é uma função bijetora, então a promessa é de fato satisfeita, especificamente para s sendo
a string de todos zeros,
e neste caso, essa é
a saída correta.
O segundo caso é que s
não é a string de todos zeros, e o que isso implica é que a função f deve ser dois para um.
Então para toda string de entrada x, existe exatamente uma outra string que f mapeia para a mesma
string que x mapeia,
e além disso, a outra string
deve ser a string que obtemos tomando o OU eXclusivo bit a bit de x com s.
Outra forma de dizer isso
é que toda string de n bits x tem uma parceira, e essa parceira é a string que obtemos
tomando o OU eXclusivo bit a bit com s.
Quaisquer duas parceiras devem nos dar
a mesma string de saída se as inserirmos em f, e nenhuma outra string pode nos dar
essa mesma string de saída.
Então essas são necessariamente strings distintas que as parceiras produzem.
Aqui está um exemplo de uma função assim descrita por sua tabela de valores.
Então esta é uma função
de 3 bits para 5 bits.
Se olharmos para esta tabela
de valores por um tempo, descobrimos que a promessa é
satisfeita para a string 011.
000 e 011 são parceiras. Aplicar XOR em qualquer uma delas
com s nos dá a outra,
e elas têm o mesmo valor de saída, que é 10011 neste caso específico, e nenhuma outra string produz
essa mesma string de saída.
001 e 010 são parceiras porque aplicar XOR em qualquer uma delas
com s dá a outra, e elas produzem o mesmo valor de saída,
que novamente, não é produzido
por nenhuma outra string.
E a situação é
similar para 100 e 111 assim como para 101 e 110.
Então se a entrada para o
problema é esta função, a resposta correta é a string 011.
Como disse antes, a maioria das funções não satisfaz esta promessa, é uma condição muito específica.
Também deve ser observado que
se a promessa é satisfeita, ela só pode ser satisfeita para uma string s.
Então há sempre apenas uma
resposta correta para este problema.
Então esse é o problema de Simon. Como disse, é difícil imaginar uma situação prática em que você queira resolver este problema,
mas esse não é o ponto. O ponto é tentar descobrir no que os computadores quânticos são bons, e resulta que eles são muito superiores
aos algoritmos clássicos para
resolver este problema específico.
Agora vamos dar uma olhada
no algoritmo de Simon, que resolve o problema de Simon.
O algoritmo consiste em
executar o quantum circuit que você vê aqui várias vezes, seguido por uma
etapa de pós-processamento clássico,
e seremos mais específicos sobre o que várias
vezes significa um pouco mais adiante.
O circuit parece muito similar
ao circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, desta vez porque a função
f mapeia n bits para m bits,
o query gate é diferente. Em vez de apenas um único
qubit na parte inferior, agora temos m qubits na parte inferior
e n na parte superior como antes.
Uma diferença importante é que não
estamos configurando um estado menos ou múltiplos estados menos na parte inferior.
Esses qubits de baixo são todos
inicializados para o estado 0, e esses estados vão diretamente
para o query gate.
Então não haverá nenhum phase kickback envolvido neste algoritmo, simplesmente não é assim que este funciona.
Fora as diferenças
que mencionei, porém, parece muito similar ao
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Aplicamos uma camada de gates Hadamard, depois aplicamos um query gate uma vez, e depois aplicamos outra
camada de gates Hadamard
seguida por medições da base padrão dos n qubits de cima.
A ideia é que cada vez que
executamos este circuit e medimos, obteremos alguma string y que nos conta algo
sobre a string oculta s
no problema de Simon. E executando o circuit
várias vezes independentemente, teremos reunido evidências estatísticas suficientes sobre s
para ser capazes de descobrir o que
ela é com alta confiança.
Agora vamos analisar o quantum
circuit para o algoritmo de Simon para ver o que ele faz.
O estado após a primeira
camada de gates Hadamard se parece com isso, similar ao que tínhamos para
o algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa.
Exceto que desta vez, os m qubits de baixo estão todos no estado 0
em vez de estados menos.
Após o query gate ser realizado, vemos que o valor f de x foi escrito nos
m qubits de baixo ou mais à esquerda,
e isso é porque f de x foi aplicado com XOR na string de todos zeros.
Então, novamente, não há phase kickback acontecendo neste algoritmo.
Em seguida realizamos a segunda
camada de gates Hadamard.
E usando a mesma fórmula de antes para a ação de uma
camada de gates Hadamard em um estado da base padrão, cat x neste caso,
como estava na fórmula original, obtemos este estado aqui, onde a ação dos gates Hadamard
fica mais aparente. Mas se quisermos, também podemos escrever o estado
de forma mais compacta como temos aqui.
Neste ponto, medimos os n qubits de cima para obter alguma string de n bits y, e só precisamos descobrir
quais são as probabilidades
para as diferentes strings. E isso nos ajudará a entender
que informação obtemos desta string y sobre a string s
que está oculta dentro da função f.
Vamos precisar de
mais espaço para isso, e realmente não precisamos mais
do diagrama do circuit, então vamos nos livrar dele e nos dar mais
espaço para a análise.
Aqui está o estado logo
antes das medições, que são medições da base padrão dos n qubits de cima ou mais à direita.
Então a medição
corresponde ao segundo cat.
Vamos denotar por p de y, a probabilidade de que as medições nos deem a string y para cada y possível.
E se seguirmos as regras da Aula 2, obtemos que cada uma dessas probabilidades é a norma Euclidiana ao quadrado de qualquer vetor tensorado
com o estado da base padrão,
correspondendo a y em
nosso vetor de estado quântico.
Isso nos dá esta expressão aqui.
Agora, para entender melhor
essas probabilidades, vamos precisar
usar alguma notação, e você talvez já conheça esta notação
porque é bastante comum em matemática.
Primeiro, quando nos referimos ao
intervalo da função f, queremos dizer simplesmente o conjunto de todas as strings que podem sair desta função.
Então é o conjunto de todos os f de x variando sobre todas as
escolhas possíveis de uma string de entrada x.
Segundo, vamos usar esta notação que você vê aqui para significar o conjunto de todas as strings de entrada x
que f mapeia para uma dada string z, para qualquer escolha de
z que queiramos considerar.
Parece um pouco com a
inversa da função f, mas não é realmente a inversa porque f não é necessariamente invertível.
Também vemos que temos
um conjunto como argumento no lado esquerdo, e neste caso, é o conjunto contendo
apenas uma única string z,
e esse é o indício que precisamos para reconhecer que não estamos falando sobre
a inversa da função f, isso é chamado de pré-imagem.
A pré-imagem pode ser
definida de forma mais geral para qualquer conjunto dado como argumento, não apenas o conjunto contendo
um único elemento,
mas isso é tudo que vamos precisar. Não é a melhor
notação do mundo porque é fácil
confundi-la com a inversa,
mas é suficientemente clara
e é amplamente usada, então vamos seguir com ela.
E agora se usarmos esta notação, podemos reescrever o vetor do qual estamos tomando a norma Euclidiana ao quadrado para obter a probabilidade para
medir cada string y.
Estamos fazendo isso porque precisamos ver
quais são os coeficientes para cada estado da base padrão individual, e isso não fica claro a partir
desta expressão aqui,
porque, em geral, podemos
ter múltiplas escolhas de x nos dando a mesma string f de x.
Em essência, tudo que estamos fazendo
é dividir a soma sobre x somando primeiro sobre todos
os z no intervalo de f,
e depois dentro dessa soma, somando sobre todos os x na pré-imagem de z, ou para ser mais preciso,
a pré-imagem do conjunto
contendo a string z.
Isso nos permite substituir f de x por z dentro do cat aqui.
E a soma geral, as diferentes strings
x que f mapeia para cada z são coletadas no
coeficiente para cada cat.
Estamos basicamente colocando strings em compartimentos, somando sobre os compartimentos, e depois somando sobre
as strings em cada compartimento,
mas isso é equivalente a simplesmente
somar sobre todas as strings.
Então de fato obtemos uma expressão que é equivalente à
que começamos,
e agora podemos calcular a
norma Euclidiana ao quadrado.
É apenas a soma dos quadrados dos valores absolutos
dos coeficientes, e então obtemos esta expressão aqui
para nossas probabilidades.
Claro, dê a si mesmo
tempo para verificar isso, se quiser fazer isso, leva tempo para se acostumar com tudo isso
e ser capaz de realizar
esses cálculos, e quanto mais prática você der a si mesmo, mais fácil ficará.
Até agora, não fizemos uso algum da promessa no problema de Simon.
Nossa análise dessas probabilidades na verdade funciona para qualquer função f, mas agora é hora de pensar sobre o problema de Simon
especificamente.
Vamos dividir as coisas nos mesmos dois casos
que tínhamos antes.
O primeiro caso é que s
é a string de todos zeros, e o segundo caso é que
s não é a string de todos zeros.
No primeiro caso, que
s é a string de todos zeros, as coisas são bem simples.
Neste caso, como vimos antes, temos que f é uma função bijetora, então existe uma única string x
que é mapeada para cada uma das
strings z no intervalo de f.
Isso torna o valor absoluto ao quadrado da soma sobre essas strings igual a 1 porque há apenas um
único termo na soma,
é mais 1 ou menos 1, mas não importa qual porque tomamos o
valor absoluto ao quadrado, e então obtemos um.
Há 2 elevado a n
elementos no intervalo de f, e sabemos disso porque f é bijetora, então há uma string no
intervalo para cada string de entrada.
E se avaliarmos a expressão inteira, descobrimos que cada string y aparece com probabilidade
um sobre dois elevado a n.
Ou seja, em outras palavras,
as medições nos dão uma string y escolhida uniformemente ao acaso.
Isso pode não parecer muito útil, mas de fato seremos capazes
de distinguir esse comportamento do comportamento que obtemos no caso
em que s não é a string de todos zeros, e vamos ver como isso vai logo.
Por ora, simplesmente observamos que se
f satisfaz a promessa no problema de Simon no caso em que s é a string de todos zeros,
então o resultado das medições é uma string aleatória uniforme.
Agora vamos para o segundo caso, que é que a promessa
é satisfeita para uma string s que não é a string de todos zeros.
Neste caso, como discutimos antes, cada string z no intervalo de f tem exatamente duas strings que mapeiam para ela,
porque toda string tem uma parceira, e cada par de parceiras
mapeia para alguma string única, e especificamente, a parceira de cada string
é a string que obtemos aplicando XOR com s.
Então se escolhermos qualquer string
z no intervalo de f, e dermos o nome w a qualquer uma das
strings que f mapeia para z,
então o XOR de w com s é a
outra string que mapeia para z.
Olhando apenas para o termo em nossa soma que corresponde a qualquer string z no intervalo que tenhamos em mente,
vemos que podemos
escrevê-lo de forma mais explícita como temos aqui.
Temos duas strings na pré-imagem de z, w e w com XOR de s.
Então podemos escrever a soma
como você vê na tela, e agora o que podemos fazer é extrair um fator de
negativo 1 elevado a w.y.
Esse fator vai ser
mais 1 ou menos 1, então desaparece quando
tomamos o valor absoluto,
e o que sobra é
esta expressão aqui.
Os detalhes não estão todos mostrados aqui, e não é necessariamente
óbvio que funciona dessa forma, mas você pode verificar que essas
duas expressões são iguais
voltando à definição
do produto escalar binário e pensando sobre o que acontece quando essas coisas estão no
expoente de negativo 1,
não diferente do que tínhamos para o
problema Bernstein-Vazirani.
Finalmente, podemos dividir esta
expressão em dois casos.
É 4 quando o produto escalar binário
de s e y é 0, e é 0 quando o produto escalar binário de s e y é 1.
Note em particular que
não há nenhuma dependência aqui de w ou z, depende apenas de s e y.
A razão de isso acontecer é
por causa da natureza muito específica e especial da promessa.
Em essência, é por isso que a promessa foi formulada desta forma, para que tudo funcionasse assim.
Novamente, toda string tem uma parceira, que obtemos aplicando XOR com
esta única string oculta s,
e é isso que faz tudo acontecer.
Agora podemos voltar à
expressão para as probabilidades e substituir os valores.
Quando s não é a string de todos zeros, há 2 elevado a n menos 1
elementos no intervalo de f,
que é metade do
número de strings de entrada, e substituindo os
valores que acabamos de calcular dá esta fórmula aqui.
Então desta vez, y não é uma
string completamente aleatória, mas sim y é uniforme sobre exatamente metade das strings de n bits,
e especificamente, é
uniforme sobre aquelas strings que têm produto escalar binário igual a 0 com s.
Agora que sabemos como o circuit
para o algoritmo de Simon funciona e especificamente quais
são as probabilidades para os diferentes resultados de medição,
resta explicar como isso nos ajuda a resolver o problema de Simon.
Resumindo o que acabamos de aprender, se for o caso de que a função f satisfaz a promessa no problema de Simon,
quando a string oculta s
é a string de todos zeros, obtemos uma string completamente aleatória das medições,
onde cada string de n bits
y é igualmente provável.
Se por outro lado, a função f satisfaz a promessa para uma string s diferente, uma que não é igual
à string de todos zeros,
então obtemos uma string aleatória y com produto escalar binário
igual a 0 com s, e entre todas essas strings,
cada y é igualmente provável.
Mas nunca obteremos uma string y com produto escalar binário
igual a 1 com s.
A pergunta se torna: "Isso é informação suficiente
para determinar s?" E a resposta, como já
sugeri, é sim,
desde que executemos o
circuit vezes suficientes.
Especificamente, vamos supor
que executamos o circuit k vezes, onde K é igual a n mais r,
onde r é algum número que vai controlar a
probabilidade de recuperarmos s.
Como exemplo, se
escolhermos r igual a 10, teremos sucesso com
probabilidade maior que 99,9%,
então não precisamos que r seja tão grande.
Em geral, a probabilidade de falha é menor que a probabilidade
de lançar uma moeda justa r vezes e obter cara toda vez.
Então se 99,9% não é suficientemente bom,
então tome r igual a 20, e a chance de falha é
menor que um em um milhão,
ou escolha qualquer r
que te deixe confortável. Você não pode garantir uma solução correta, mas pode tornar a
probabilidade de erro negligenciável
para todos os efeitos práticos.
Aqui estamos nomeando essas
strings y1 a yk, onde estamos usando sobrescritos para nos ajudar a nomear essas strings,
apenas para que possamos reservar subscritos para nos referir aos bits individuais
dessas strings.
Então esses não são expoentes
ou nada parecido, são apenas os nomes que estamos dando a essas k strings.
Cada uma tem comprimento n porque as obtivemos
ao executar o circuit para o algoritmo de Simon.
Então podemos escrever os
bits individuais dessas k strings como você vê aqui.
O que fazemos agora é criar uma matriz m, onde cada entrada desta matriz é um bit, e obtemos esses bits das strings
que acabamos de medir, exatamente como mostrado aqui.
Então esta matriz tem k linhas e n colunas, e suas entradas são todas valores binários.
Agora, não sabemos o que é s. É isso que estamos tentando encontrar, mas apenas imagine por um
momento que soubéssemos s,
e formássemos um vetor coluna
a partir dos bits de s, como mostrado aqui.
Se multiplicarmos esse vetor por m e depois tomarmos o resultado módulo-2, ou outra forma de dizer isso
é que substituímos a adição
pelo OU eXclusivo, então necessariamente
obteremos o vetor de todos zeros.
Isso é porque cada uma das
entradas neste vetor resultante não é nada mais do que o produto escalar binário de s
com uma das linhas de m.
Se S for a string de todos zeros, sempre obteremos o vetor zero do produto escalar binário.
E se s não é a string de todos zeros, obteremos isso a partir do que
sabemos sobre as probabilidades para as strings y1 a yk aparecerem.
Em particular, o
produto escalar binário com s é sempre zero para todas essas strings.
Uma forma simples de dizer isso é que este vetor
formado pelos bits de s está sempre no espaço nulo da matriz m,
assumindo que estamos fazendo toda a
nossa aritmética módulo-2, mas claro, não sabemos o que é s,
estamos tentando encontrar s.
Mas o que podemos fazer é calcular o
espaço nulo desta matriz m, novamente, módulo-2.
Especificamente, podemos fazer isso usando a técnica de
eliminação de Gauss, que é o procedimento frequentemente ensinado
em cursos introdutórios de álgebra linear.
Funciona perfeitamente bem quando fazemos toda a nossa aritmética módulo-2, e pode ser feito de forma bastante
eficiente com um computador.
E se calcularmos o espaço nulo de m, dada a forma específica em que essas k strings foram
escolhidas aleatoriamente,
seremos capazes de recuperar s com probabilidade maior que
1 menos 2 elevado ao negativo r.
Para ser específico, o que veremos com probabilidade maior que
1 menos 2 elevado ao negativo r é que o espaço nulo
inclui o vetor de todos zeros,
como sempre faz para toda matriz, bem como o vetor correspondente a s, seja ele o vetor de todos zeros ou não.
E o mais importante, nenhum outro vetor vai
aparecer no espaço nulo.
Na verdade, não é muito difícil provar isso, embora eu não vá entrar em detalhes.
A ideia é que se
tivermos alguma outra string que não é o vetor de todos zeros
e não é s, então cada uma das strings aleatórias, y1 a yk,
vai basicamente eliminá-la
do espaço nulo com probabilidade de metade.
Então após k execuções, é muito improvável
que ela sobreviva, e na verdade, nenhuma das
strings que não pertencem
é provável que sobreviva. E um fato muito simples
da teoria das probabilidades, conhecido como o limite da união, pode
ser usado para estabelecer isso.
Não expliquei todos
os detalhes aqui, mas espero que você entenda a ideia de que ao calcular o espaço nulo módulo-2 desta matriz m,
é muito provável que recuperemos s, e é assim que o algoritmo de Simon
resolve o problema de Simon.
Só resta uma coisa
a dizer sobre o problema de Simon, e diz respeito à
dificuldade clássica deste problema,
ou seja, quantas consultas um algoritmo de consulta clássico precisa para resolver o problema de Simon?
A resposta é: muitas, em geral.
Existem diferentes enunciados precisos
que podem ser feitos sobre a
dificuldade clássica deste problema, e aqui está apenas um deles.
Se tivermos qualquer
algoritmo de consulta probabilístico e esse algoritmo fizer menos de 2 elevado a n dividido por 2
menos 1, menos 1 consultas,
então esse é um número de consultas
que é exponencial em n, e esse algoritmo vai falhar
ao resolver o problema de Simon,
com probabilidade de pelo menos metade.
Às vezes, provar
resultados de impossibilidade como este pode ser muito desafiador, mas este não é muito difícil de provar
por meio de uma análise
probabilística elementar.
Não vou fazer isso nesta aula em vídeo, e vou me concentrar apenas
na intuição por trás disso.
Estamos tentando encontrar a string oculta s, mas enquanto não consultarmos a função em duas strings com
o mesmo valor de saída,
teremos informações muito limitadas
sobre s.
Basicamente, tudo que aprendemos é
que a string oculta s não é o OU eXclusivo de quaisquer duas strings distintas
que consultamos,
E se consultarmos a função em menos do que esse número de consultas, ainda haverá muitas escolhas de s
que não foram descartadas.
Esta não é uma prova formal,
mas essa é a ideia básica.
Então, em resumo, o algoritmo de Simon nos fornece uma vantagem marcante do quântico sobre os algoritmos
clássicos dentro do modelo de consulta.
Em particular, o algoritmo de Simon
resolve o problema de Simon com um número de consultas que é linear no número de bits de entrada
n para nossa função,
enquanto qualquer algoritmo clássico,
mesmo que seja probabilístico, precisa fazer um número de
consultas que é exponencial em n
para resolver o problema de Simon com uma probabilidade razoável de sucesso.
É verdade que o problema de Simon é um problema um tanto artificial que presumivelmente ninguém
realmente quer resolver,
mas isso é secundário. Às vezes, as ideias precisam ser desenvolvidas antes de serem colocadas em prática.
E de fato, Peter Shor declarou claramente que foi o algoritmo de Simon que inspirou seu agora
famoso algoritmo quântico
para fatoração de inteiros, que veremos em algumas aulas.
E esse é o fim da Aula 5.
Nesta aula, demos uma olhada no
modelo de consulta de computação, e vimos uma progressão de exemplos
de algoritmos quânticos
que exibem vantagens sobre os algoritmos clássicos
dentro deste modelo.
Há, de fato, muito mais
conhecido sobre o modelo de consulta e algoritmos quânticos para outros problemas que
não discuti.
Então se você achar este
modelo interessante, há bastante
mais para aprender sobre ele.
Nosso próximo passo será nos afastar
do modelo de consulta e em direção a um modelo de computação
mais representativo
dos tipos de problemas que esperamos poder resolver na prática.
Espero que você se junte a mim para a Aula 6, onde vamos nos concentrar principalmente em
estabelecer uma base para o estudo de algoritmos quânticos.
E a partir daí, passaremos para alguns
algoritmos quânticos específicos, incluindo o algoritmo de Shor
para fatoração de inteiros
em aulas subsequentes. Até logo!